So what if I told you that the very same entry level workers who are currently using artificial intelligence the most intensely in the corporate world are also the exact same workers who are quietly vanishing from the broader economy?
It's a massive contradiction.
Right. It is a huge structural contradiction. And to understand what is actually going on inside the modern workplace, we really have to look past the endless hype and, well, the self-reported surveys.
Yeah, the surveys.
You know the ones I mean. It feels like every single week there's a new survey making some sweeping claim like, oh, 90% of workers say AI does half their job.
Right, right.
But the
problem is survey data is incredibly flawed it's basically the equivalent of asking someone what they think they spend their money on rather than you know just looking at their actual credit card statement
oh that is a perfect way to frame it because i mean human memory is just notoriously unreliable especially when it comes to adopting new behaviors
right
right we tend to overestimate How much we use a shiny new tool because we feel like we're supposed to be using it. And then we totally underestimate the mundane everyday tasks we actually spend our hours doing.
Yeah, elderly.
Surveys are just, they're too coarse of an instrument when you're trying to measure a real-time technological revolution. You just end up measuring sentiment.
Yeah.
Reality.
Which brings us to the core mission for today's deep dive. We are throwing out the surveys for you listening right now. We have a stack of actual research in front of us. Yeah. But the absolute crown jewel is this brand new paper published on August
12th, 2026. Yeah. It's called. How Organizations Use AI Evidence from ChatGPT, authored by researchers from OpenAI, Columbia Business School, and Wharton. And this paper is completely unprecedented because the researchers, well, they didn't ask anyone what they were
doing.
No, they didn't have to.
Right. They used OpenAI's own internal administrative records from ChatGPT Enterprise.
And the scale of this data set is something we really need to emphasize for you. The researchers linked these administrative records to worker job titles, message level task classifications, and this is huge for public companies, their actual financial data through
Compostat.
Wow.
Yeah, going all the way through March 2026. So if we look just at the worker-level sample, we are talking about 1,764 organizations and exactly 17,446,551 messages. Over 17.4 million. Right. And crucially, they measured this usage at a common horizon, exactly 26 weeks after each firm adopted the technology.
Now, I know what you might be thinking. When you hear about researchers analyzing 17 million internal corporate chats, that sounds incredibly invasive.
Oh, absolutely.
It sounds like a total privacy nightmare.
Yeah, it's a very valid concern, and we should clear that up immediately. This is a strictly privacy-preserving aggregate analysis. No researcher ever sat down and read individual customer prompts or messages. Right. The messages were classified into categories by an automated classifier. The entire goal
was to look at the macro-level telemetry data, the overarching patterns of how work is changing, without ever compromising the specific proprietary content of what a company was actually typing into the prompt box.
Okay, so we know how we're looking at the data. We're looking at the raw telemetry. So let's dive into what that telemetry actually tells us. Let's start with the sheer volume of use because the big cynical question floating around the business world has been, are companies actually using
this software or are they just buying the licenses, putting out a press release and then forgetting about it?
Well, the data absolutely destroys that cynical narrative. I mean, the growth is staggering. The aggregate ChatGPT enterprise output tokens grew roughly sevenfold between June 2025 and March 2026.
Wait, sevenfold in less than a year?
Yeah.
That is massive. But is that just OpenAI signing up a bunch of new clients left and right?
See, that is the crucial distinction to make here. It isn't just new logos. The usage grew roughly fourfold within the fixed cohort of firms that had already adopted the tool by June 2025.
Wait, let me make sure I understand the mechanics of that. You're saying that if we draw a circle around the companies that already had the software deployed as of June 2025, and we don't add any new companies to that circle, the volume of AI work being done inside that
specific circle still quadrupled.
Exactly. So about half of the massive overall growth came from existing customers deepening their use. They weren't just, you know, trying it out and abandoning it. They were embedding it much deeper into their workflows. Wow. Furthermore, the data shows that usage accelerated across every
single adoption cohort simultaneously in early 2026. So
no honeymoon phase.
Right. It wasn't a honeymoon phase that tapers off. Everyone, regardless of when they bought the software, stepped on the gas at the exact same time.
That implies a sort of collective aha moment across the corporate world. But here's what I find fascinating about this. We actually have some older background data to contrast this against.
Oh, the consumer paper.
Yes. The lead author on this new enterprise paper also wrote an older paper called How People Use Chat GPT. But that older paper looked at consumer accounts, you know, people at home. And in that consumer data, personal non-work
use actually overtook work use. It hit over 70% of all messages. People were using it to write creative fiction, plan family vacations, ask for dinner recipes based on what was in their fridge, that sort of thing.
It's a brilliant contrast because it shows how context dictates behavior. The consumer side might be 70% personal, but the moment you move inside a paid workplace deployment like Chad GPT Enterprise, the mix flips entirely.
It's all business. Strictly business. The enterprise telemetry shows workers doing heavy production work, technical writing, coding, data analysis, and professional communication. It is a completely different behavioral landscape once the software sits behind the corporate firewall.
OK, so if existing companies are using it four times as much as they were a year ago and they're using it for heavy, productive work, it forces a question. Who are these companies? Because rolling out enterprise software to thousands of people isn't cheap. Are these nimble, agile
tech startups or are we talking about massive traditional conglomerates?
Right now, enterprise AI is overwhelmingly a big company game. When we look at U.S. public companies in the data set, the adopters are dramatically larger than the non-adopters across every possible metric. The median revenue for an adopting firm is roughly $2.27
billion. Billion? Yes, compared to just under $210 million for non-adopters.
I mean, that is essentially a 10x difference in revenue.
Yeah. And it holds true across the board. Median employment is 2,934 workers for adopters versus just 424 for non-adopters.
Wow.
Median market value is nearly $5 billion for adopters versus about $316 million. And if you look at median R&D expense, it's $113.1 million for the adopting companies versus less than $10 million for the non-adopters.
The scale of the companies leading the chart is just undeniable. But the paper has this one specific stat that stood out to me, though it is a bit dense. It says that a one log point increase in lagged revenue is associated with a one point one percentage
point higher probability of adoption.
Right.
Well, let's translate that for those of us who haven't been in a statistics class recently. What does a one log point increase actually mean in plain English?
Essentially, it means that for every massive multiplier in a company's past revenue, every time you scale the financial size of the company exponentially, their likelihood of adopting AI jumps significantly.
Okay.
If you want the most extreme plain English version. The absolute titans of industry are the ones buying this. Firms in the top revenue quartile are 6.9 percentage points more likely to adopt. And if you look at the top 5% of the absolute megacorporations, they are
9.8 points more likely to adopt. And within specific industries and years, those numbers actually jump to 7.2 and 11.3 points.
Wait, pause for a second. Because the researchers also pointed out that it isn't just about having a massive pile of cash, right? Right,
exactly.
The adoption strongly tracks accumulated intangible capital. And the strongest association they found was with a company's SG&A stock per employee, selling general and administrative expenses. The coefficient there is 0.020, which was
higher than capitalized software at 0.008 and higher than R&D stock at 0.004. Are we basically saying that companies with more middle managers, more human resources staff and bigger administrative overhead are adopting AI
faster? Why on earth would that be the case? Wouldn't heavy administration just, you know, slow you down?
It seems totally counterintuitive until you understand what SG&A actually represents in an economic sense. SG&A is a proxy for organizational maturity and infrastructure. To understand why this matters, we have to pull in a foundational theory from a background paper by Bryn Jolfsson, Rock, and Syverson.
It's about something called the productivity J-curve.
The J-curve. Okay, let's unpack that.
So when a true general-purpose technology like electricity or the internet, or now generative AI is first introduced, its measured impact on a company's productivity actually looks flat or even negative at first. That's the dip in the J.
Right. Because they're spending money.
Exactly. They are spending money buying the technology, but they aren't getting immediate output. Instead, they're quietly building organizational capital that doesn't show up on a traditional balance sheet. They're redesigning workflows, retraining their staff, arguing
with legal about security protocols and inventing new operational standards.
Oh, I see. So it's like buying a gym membership versus actually building muscle. Yes. Any company can swipe the corporate card and buy the gym membership, the AI licenses. But if you don't have the internal infrastructure, the trainers, the schedules, the culture of fitness, which is what that SG&A overhead
basically represents, nobody is actually going to get stronger. The tool just sits there.
Precisely. Co-invention is a remarkably slow and messy process. The fact that chat GPT enterprise adoption correlates so strongly with SG&A and capitalized software is a direct empirical echo of this J-curve argument.
These massive companies have the administrative muscle to actually deploy and integrate the tool, not just purchase it.
Although I feel like we should explicitly note the author's own caveats here before we get too carried away. Definitely. They are very clear that these are conditional associations, not strictly causal relationships. And because this specific sample relies on Compostat data, which is entirely U.S. public companies,
it tells us absolutely nothing about what small private firms or nimble little startups are doing.
Right. A very necessary caveat. But if we accept that we are currently looking at these massive, intangible, rich public corporations, They bought the gym membership. They have the administrative trainers to set up the schedules.
Which naturally leads to the next question. Who inside these giant companies is actually doing the heavy lifting? Who is on the floor using the machines?
This brings us to what I think is the most fascinating revelation in the entire data set. It is a beautiful split between what economists call the extensive margin and the intensive margin.
OK, let's use an analogy here to make sure we're totally clear on these terms. If we think about a new smartphone app, the extensive margin is basically how many people downloaded the app and opened it at least once this week. It's just measuring who is present.
The intensive margin is of the people who opened it, who is spending four hours a day swiping and tapping, and who is just checking it for two seconds.
Exactly. Reach versus death. So let's look at the extensive margin first, who is present and active. The answer is basically everyone across the org chart.
Really? Everyone?
Yeah. At the average firm in the data set, managers and directors make up about 24% of the weekly active users. Individual contributors and professionals make up 15%. Senior individual contributors and principals are at 13%, and executives are at
about 10%.
Okay, and what about the junior staff, the trainees?
Early career workers and trainees make up only about 7% of the weekly active users.
Which totally upends the stereotype. The cultural assumption is always that young digital natives are the ones driving new technology adoption. Exactly. We actually have an older background paper from Aylan Du and colleagues called GPTs are GPTs, which try to
estimate occupational exposure to AI. by comparing what the models were capable of against written job descriptions.
Right. The capabilities frame.
Yeah. But this new data shows us the difference between what a model could do and what workers actually do.
Yes. And it proves a vital point.
Yeah.
Exposure is not adoption. Adoption is not use. Just because a task can be automated doesn't mean the person doing it logs in to ChatGPT. And conversely, just because a senior manager logs in once a week doesn't mean they are fundamentally changing how they work.
To really see how they are working, we have to look at the tasks themselves. What are all these managers and executives actually doing when they log in? The researchers categorize the messages, and the use cases are incredibly broad. If we look at task prevalence, meaning what percentage of users tried a
specific task, 56.3% of active users used it for documentation and technical writing. 49.6% used it for technical, digital, and electronic work. 41.1% used it for drafting interpersonal messages like emails. And
38.9% used it for getting topic overviews.
Oh, and don't forget the rest of the list. Facts and figures, professional work and market research sat at 21.4%, sales, planning, and legal at 17.2%, data analysis was 15.5%, and financial and tax at 14.9%. That's a huge spread.
It is. But here is where we have to separate reach from depth again. That was task prevalence.
Right.
If we look at message share meaning, out of the 17.4 million total prompts, where did the raw volume actually go? The picture changes entirely. Documentation and technical writing consumed 18.3% of all messages. Technical digital work took 12.7%.
Interpersonal messages dropped to 11.9%. And then there's a massive 27.3% chunk that is just a residual all other category out of 60 possible past categories.
Okay, let's talk about why that happens. Why does drafting an email reach 41% of users, but only make up roughly 12% of a volume, while technical writing eats up nearly a fifth of all the prompt sent?
It comes down to the mechanics of the work. If an executive wants AI to draft a polite decline to an invitation, that takes one, maybe two prompts. You get the output, you copy it, you leave. It has broad reach but low depth.
Oh, okay.
But if a software engineer or a technical writer is using AI to help document a complex new code base, they aren't just sending one prompt. They're iterating. They're pasting code, getting an explanation, asking for revisions, refining the format. It requires a
deep, continuous conversation.
And what about that 27.3% all other category? I mean, that seems like a massive blind spot.
It's actually evidence of how flexible the tool is. That giant all other bucket proves there's a massive long tail of highly specific niche workflows. It reinforces that generative AI is a general purpose technology. People are adapting it to the weird idiosyncratic needs
of their specific desks.
Okay, here is where this deep dive gets really intense. We talked about the extensive margin who has the app open, and we saw that executives and managers were everywhere, while early career workers and trainees made up only 7% of the users. Right.
But what happens when we flip to the intensive margin? Who is generating all that raw volume? Who is sitting there iterating on technical writing all day?
The seniority gradient reverses and it reverses hard.
Wow.
Those early career workers and trainees might be a tiny slice of the overall user base, but they send roughly eight to nine more weekly messages than the average active user in their exact same firm. Meanwhile, the managers, the directors, the executives who make up the bulk of the user
base send fewer messages than average. Analysts and marketing staff are also incredibly high intensity users.
Let that sink in. The executives are scanning their badges, walking into the gym, doing one set on the bench press, and leaving. They're present, but they aren't sweating. Down in the crunches, the youngest, most junior employees are running a
marathon on the treadmill every single week. They're leaning on this technology harder than anyone else in the building.
Which brings us to the sharpest tension in this entire analysis. It's a phenomenon we need to look at very closely. We can call it the junior paradox.
The junior paradox. I like that.
To understand the stakes of what these young workers are doing, we have to look at two deeply conflicting pieces of background research that frame this exact moment in economic history.
Okay, let's start with the optimistic perspective. In a paper titled Generative AI at Work by Brynjolfsson, Liu, and Raymond, researchers studied over 5,000 customer support agents, and they found a 15% average productivity gain when generative
AI was introduced. But the critical finding was who got that game. It was concentrated almost entirely in the least experienced, lowest skilled workers.
Exactly. The 20-year veterans saw almost no improvement.
Right.
Because the AI acted as a great leveler. It essentially took the accumulated tacit knowledge, you know, the subtle tricks of the trade that the veterans had spent a decade learning, and it handed that knowledge directly to the novice on their first day. The optimistic view is that
AI makes junior workers vastly more capable, effectively upskilling them overnight so they can perform at a much higher level.
But then you have the darker, much more pessimistic view. Just a few days before this new enterprise paper was published, there was an August 2026 revision of another paper by Brynjolfsson, Chandar and Chen. It is chillingly
titled Canaries in the Coal Mine.
Yeah, that one is heavy.
They didn't use surveys either. They used ADP payroll data tracking millions of real employment records through June 2026. And they found that employment for 22 to 25 year olds in exposed occupations is sitting 19 percent below where it would be if it had just
tracked along with their less exposed peers.
A 19 percent gap is a massive demographic hole in the workforce. And the authors noted that this gap has widened steadily since they first documented it in August 2025.
And the mechanism is important here. It's not happening through mass headline grabbing layoffs. It is operating through a quiet, sustained freeze in hiring. It's highly concentrated in occupations where AI substitutes for human tasks
rather than augmenting them.
So now we have to take this brand new finding from the ChatGPT Enterprise telemetry and place it squarely in the middle of these two older papers. We had a profound contradiction.
Right.
Conditional on being employed at an adopting firm, the very workers whose entry-level jobs appear to be quietly vanishing from the broader economy are the exact same workers using the tool the hardest.
So what does this actually mean? Because the implications are wildly different depending on how you read it. Is this heavy junior use, jumping use by which these young workers become productive enough to keep their jobs? Are they looking around at the hiring freezes, realizing the bar has been raised and thinking, I have to use AI
for eight extra tasks a week just to survive the cuts?
Or is it the exact opposite mechanism? Are they using AI so heavily and becoming so hyperproductive that one entry-level kid is now easily absorbing the workload of what used to be three entry-level hires?
Oh, man. Right.
If that is the case, their heavy use is effectively destroying the future junior jobs for their peers.
It feels like the defining economic question of this decade. So looking at the data from OpenAI, Columbia and Wharton, which one is it? Are they surviving or are they automating away their peers?
Well, the truth is we have to be completely intellectually honest with you. The lead paper does not answer that question.
It doesn't. It
can't. The telemetry data is brilliant for showing us the intensity of use. It shows us exactly what tasks are consuming the most volume, but it cannot tell us the macroeconomic destiny of that 23-year-old analyst sending all those prompts. It leaves us sitting with an
unresolved, incredibly profound tension about the future of work.
Which honestly changes how I visualize a corporate office right now. You have the executives feeling like they've successfully deployed AI because they log in to draft a quick email once a week. And meanwhile, down in the trenches, the youngest workers are practically plugged into the
matrix, churning out complex documentation and technical work at light speed, while the empty desks next to them just stay empty because the company quietly stopped hiring.
Yeah. If we pull back from the debate on junior workers for a moment, the ultimate takeaway synthesized by the researchers across all this data is a crucial fundamental distinction. Adoption is not deployment.
Buying the gym membership is not working out.
Precisely. Firms are not just flipping a switch and deciding whether to use generative AI. They're undergoing a very slow, very messy, very human process of learning where it actually belongs in their daily workflows. Right. And this leads to a sobering implication for the broader
economy. We established earlier that the biggest, most valuable, most intangible rich firms are the ones adopting earliest and integrating best because they have the SG&A infrastructure to support the J curve.
So if a broadly available technology like ChatGPT is integrated most effectively by the absolute titans of industry, it could actually widen the gap between superstar firms and the rest of the economy. We always love to think of software as a
great democratizing force. But in this early phase, it might actually be an engine for inequality between companies.
Exactly. That's a very real possibility.
Before we wrap this up, we need to explicitly run through the limitations of everything we've discussed today just to keep us all grounded in reality. The researchers are very transparent about the scope of their data, and we need to be, too. First, this analysis is based on ChatGPT
Enterprise only. Right. It does not include Microsoft Copilot. It does not include Anthropix Cloud. It doesn't include API usage, in-house custom-built tools, or anyone using personal accounts at work.
Second, the job title coverage in their data set is incomplete. We have the breakdown of who is using it by title, but we don't have the denominator, meaning we don't know the total number of employees in those specific roles across all 1,700 companies. Because of that, we don't have a
true, precise parole adoption rate.
Third, and this is crucial, message counts measure intensity. They do not measure economic value. Oh, absolutely. One brilliant strategic prompt from an executive that redirects a product launch might generate a million dollars of value,
while 10 rapid-fire prompts from a trainee might just be fixing a formatting error in a spreadsheet. Volume does not equal impact.
And finally, none of the financial results we discussed. The revenue correlations, the market cap advantages are causal. We absolutely cannot say that AI caused those financial outcomes. Only that massive financial scale is strongly associated with early adoption.
The authors readily admit all of this themselves, and our analysis is better for keeping those boundaries clear. But as we look at this unprecedented peak inside the actual real world credit card statement of enterprise AI, I want to leave you with one final provocative thought to mull over.
Go for it.
We spent a lot of time debating the junior paradox. We see the executives barely scratching the surface of the tool and the entry level trainees using it with massive unprecedented intensity. But if the heavy use of AI by junior employees ends up permanently
shrinking the pipeline of entry-level jobs, if companies just stop hiring as many 22-year-olds because the ones they have are doing the work of three people, where will the next generation of managers and executives come from in 10 years? If you automate away the
entry-level training ground today, who is going to be left with the institutional knowledge to actually run the company tomorrow?
It is a structural time bomb that just isn't showing up on any corporate balance sheet right now.
Exactly. Thank you so much for joining us on this deep dive into the real data behind the AI revolution. Until next time, keep questioning the surveys and keep looking for the actual numbers.